i love that movie from beginning to end
and then i went online one day and i saw
the reviews and i'm like
i was like what
i don't get it this movie was incredible
why is it so hard to make a great movie
hmm a good one
i think one it depends on your
definition of great
i think that so many people are caught
up and everybody else said it was great
and i think that's where most movies go
wrong
somebody will tell somebody oh your
movie's like this but with a little bit
of that and they go
i didn't see that but okay and then they
go back and they start looking at that
movie and they want to polish it now and
make it a little bit more like that
movie and it's it's that whole
it's that whole like looking at the guy
next to you thing
you know and judging yourself by how far
you've gotten ahead of everybody else
that you're that is your peer or your
you know your colleague or whatnot
trying to try to just get ahead of them
and judging yourself judging your
success by how much more success you've
had than them
and that includes making a great movie
i consider a great movie to be one where
i watched that movie and i couldn't turn
it off
i couldn't turn it off
that's watching it though i couldn't
turn it off um
one of
one of my favorite movies
uh
is 44 inch chest nobody's seen it
um well i shouldn't say that let me not
say nobody's seen it
most people in the u.s haven't seen it
but it's called 44 inch chest i love
that movie from beginning to end and
then i went online one day and i saw the
reviews and i'm like i was like what
i don't get it this movie was incredible
i mean i i couldn't take my eyes off the
screen it was so well written
um
every element of filmmaking was done
to the nth degree i just didn't
understand it right
so i don't know if
certain people walked away going i guess
we didn't make a great movie you know
i felt they made a great movie
i felt they made one of the best movies
ever i did and it's a small little movie
takes place in a flat you know
i think it's an incredible movie i think
it's a great movie
a lot of other people didn't think so
but maybe the person who made the movie
said that's exactly what i wanted to
make
because that's how i would feel
when i sit down and i watch a film of
mine it's all about how much of what was
in here made it on the screen
and if it made it on the screen it went
one day when i get to
at least 93 percent of whatever i wanted
to being on the screen i'm gonna say
that's a great movie that's a great
movie
that's a successful movie
i've made something successful
because that's what success means to me
that's what a great movie made by me
means right
and i'm hopeful that that person who
made 44 inch chest felt that way because
maybe people don't feel that that was a
great movie
you said it was a foreign film
it's it's made in the uk um
it has uh
ray
uh
it's going to bother me that i can't
remember his name but um
leota no no no no not rayleigh uh he was
in he was in uh um
uh
the
the jack nicholson movie when he played
the gangster the irish gangster
um
with leonardo dicaprio and
uh
all those guys i can't remember his name
right off the top of my head but you've
seen him a million times and when you
see 44 hours oh fine
no it's like i want to say it's like roy
i mean ray like i don't know why i want
to call it like bird or something
like that but i know that's not what it
is but it's
as soon as you see him you're gonna say
oh that guy no you know but it's it's
him so many people so many names so many
people that you're gonna recognize
immediately right as soon as it starts
you're gonna see four people you've seen
in every movie you've ever seen and
you're gonna say oh
okay but they're all uk actors right
and the story is very simple
there's a 44 inch chest and there's a
guy inside of there and the main
character the protagonist is trying to
decide should he kill him or not kill
him
very simple premise he invites his
friends over his friends are gangsters
just like he's a gangster and they're
trying to help him work through his
problem
to decide if he should kill this guy do
you know who this guy is
this is the guy that's been sleeping
with his wife
in the whole movie i'm not ruining it
that's the movie they're trying to
decide should he kill the guy or
shouldn't he
that's the whole movie and i'm telling
you it is a perfect movie from start to
finish
does it take place in one room
it doesn't take place in one room but
definitely in one one flat okay one flat
it it's um
incred it's is done to
an incredible level of filmmaking
writing directing
editing score everything is incredible
the acting is impeccable
the special effects are impactable yes
there are special effects even in this
this small film um everything was done
so perfectly so the definition of great
is really
you know kind of subjective in terms of
why is it so hard to make a great movie
i think
if you have succeeded at accomplishing
what you wanted to accomplish and you
you feel successful in it
it's a great movie in terms of one that
you've made
now if you are talking about
just watching movies yeah there's a lot
of movies that will let you down you
know and maybe maybe maybe this person
who thinks that they made a great movie
was just like a guy who i was telling
you about who stunted his growth because
all he's concerned about is how he
measures up against the other filmmakers
that he knows in his peer group
and if he's thinking about that
and he's constantly throwing in stuff
and falling back on bad habits and never
growing
he may be satisfied but he hasn't made a
great movie
you know i think that you have to be
beyond that um one of the
one of the best uh
you know quotes is is from uh the art of
war where it talks about you know making
yourself invincible right
and invincible doesn't mean
that you can't uh that you win that
doesn't mean you win um all that
invincible means is putting yourself
beyond the possibility of defeat and the
only way to do that is by truly knowing
yourself you should truly know yourself
and not
spend your time so concerned with what
everybody else is doing it's one of the
reasons why i took down my personal
profile on facebook i don't want to know
what everybody else is working i just
want to focus i just want to focus and i
want to grow that's all i want to do is
focus and grow
and so
you have to be without that vanity you
have to be without that ego so that you
you have the ability to grow and when
you are making something
you're constantly growing and getting
better and you can understand what
didn't work what did work
you can understand how could i have
better communicated that so that it
ended up on the screen the way that i
wanted it to
and
how close did i get to the vision that i
had in my head
how close did i really truly get
and even with one to one where i
considered to be
my best film to date if you ask me how
close i got i'd say 75 if i'm being
generous with myself from being generous
with myself i got 75
i'm trying to get in the 90s
and so that i can consider it a great
film
so that i can consider it a successful
i find that our greatest enemy besides
constant comparing yourselves to your
peers
the enemy of great
um or the enemy of good is sometimes
trying to be great as opposed to just
trying to make the best movie possible
you're trying to be great
don't try to be great just try to be
truthful and honest to the story
to your characters
try that
be as honest and truthful as you can in
that moment that story like i said made
that truth may not resonate with
everybody in the sense of it's their
truth
but they have to understand that you
were being honest when you were making
this film